[Music]
when I go to work I am as excited as I
was when I first came here and that that
sense that this is not just about you
succeeding as an actor that this is not
just about you it's about the play is
something that I learned definitely here
acting when done right Theatre when done
right it is a noble profession you are
reflecting the human condition back to
people and so it's a it's a really I'm
so happy I'm an actor you need to start
giving back now you need to start
behaving as if you were successful
without being stupid or arrogant behave
as if you were successful now because
there's a great need for you
and your talents and your creativity and
your thing that you love is a great need
for you to be out there spreading that
in the world with a great deal of love
well I learned that at Carnegie Mellon
University